I got a question for you it's a what-if
question yeah what's up one of your
company announced to the world that they
are investing in the development of
robots that will eventually take your
job if you're a driver for uber and lyft
that's actually the thing that's
happened so I really like uber and lyft
they've made la city where I live in way
more navigable I also love that it gives
you a chance to meet people that you
never get a chance to meet otherwise so
there's basically two kinds of drivers
people who are doing it full-time
there's someone who have been
professional drivers for years it's the
first off key say my name is Juan I'm
from Mexico and I will fall but I'm
driving around
all update and then there's the people
who are doing it to fill in the gaps who
are maybe they're artists or students or
people of other jobs like Instagram and
YouTube it's not like that so I want to
know what drivers thought about this
change and the first thing I learned is
they are not especially worried yeah
take a right just right before please I
don't think anybody is gonna be or not a
lot of people are gonna have that peace
of mind of driving with with a computer
you know and even without like a really
good technology the technology going
down you know sometimes the internet and
everything
that I think yeah so you're not worried
and the worry about it maybe in like 20
25 25 is nine years away but the truth
is driverless cars are gonna be here
sooner than we think so my colleague in
New York Jonna her beat is the future of
Transportation I'm j-money booyah I am
the reporter for a future of
Transportation at BuzzFeed news and we
want to talk to is like oh I don't think
that's gonna happen around things to
happen for for 20 or 30 years yeah so
fully autonomous vehicles are probably
further down the road 20 or 30 years
seems reasonable but level for
autonomous vehicles are probably going
to be on the road within 10 years some
general motors for example is releasing
a feature called super cruise which will
allow you on the highway to take your
hands completely off the steering wheel
and as long as you're paying attention
and there's not anything else going on
and that will be in production by 2017
so we're getting really close to what we
hope will be level for automation
meaning you will not have to put your
hands on the wheel for a long period of
time both on the highway and in dense
urban areas so there's lots of car
companies beginning to test their own
release new self-driving features one of
the most advanced on our market right
now is Tesla so I went down to the
design center in Hawthorne to check out
the latest software for their Model S
okay
that little stick the dart now pull that
twice towards yourself
Hamilton
and showing blue lines right now many
minutes reading there's really like the
lands right now
it's super I mean it's not like cruise
control so if I turn if I put the the
right turn signal on is gonna go into
the right leg it's off
it's so tight
I really wish I could just be right go
back to Tesla that's I mean in in the
future these cars will be fully
autonomous so yes they will at some
point have to be capable of doing
multitude of different things if we have
level 4 cars do we still need we won't
need them in these traditional sense
that we need them now they won't
necessarily need to be driving but there
has to be a person behind the wheel for
level 4 autonomous vehicles and so what
that looks like
it is really unclear because we're
really early on in the stages lifts just
announced its partnership with General
Motors they're not even really sure what
that is going to look like they've
really just begun conceptualizing it and
so there's an opportunity for drivers to
simply sit behind the wheel between
rides but the likelihood that a driver
would be interested in doing something
like that I'd to me I would assume it's
very low it's really not clear what the
drivers place will be when there's even
level for autonomous vehicles I did ask
a lyft what their plans for drivers were
and they said well it will be years
until we roll out an on-demand
autonomous network we believe that
autonomous vehicles are the future of
Transportation having pioneered a
peer-to-peer ride-sharing lyft will
continue to play a leadership role in
the evolution of how we get around we
have a strong driver community and we
are dedicated to treating them better
than any other ride-sharing platform
that won't change we will work closely
with drivers and explore ways for them
to participate in shaping the future
they don't care about self-driving cars
it's that they're not really thinking
about driving for uber lyft as a
long-term thing
and that could be because it's thinking
about what's next
that's because I feel like lived do your
filler position and feel like your hands
go away I'm gonna be a lyft driver for
the next five years like that should not
be something that's just implanted into
your brain ever like don't realize this
kind of
I guess it's like a gig it's not like a
fully shouldn't be a full-time job it
was never implemented it was never
created to take people away from a
full-time job and that's where a lot of
drivers the beginning thing it's so
excited because the money was so good
they quit their job they bought new cars
they did all these things to tailor to
live to deliver and then they didn't
realize that obviously over time it's a
business especially a tech business is
going to change their models and that's
gonna affect what they're making and so
I just don't think this was ever meant
to be permanent for people
you